la velocidad de propagación de la
variante de omicron del cob y 19.000 ya
se ha quintuplicado el país registró
este viernes 117 mil 100 casos una cifra
inédita
esta es una gran preocupación un gran
desafío hemos visto que durante los
últimos ocho días la cifra ha subido
mucho de 10 mil casos por día a más de
100.000 en sólo 8 días entonces con esta
velocidad el número va a ser mucho mayor
que las oleadas anteriores
según el ministerio de salud de india ya
son 35 dos millones en total de casos
reportados desde el principio de la
pandemia pasar la barrera de los 100 mil
contagios diarios le llegó a esta nación
de 1350 millones de habitantes casi
siete meses durante la primera ola y
casi cuatro en la segunda
nueva delhi entrará en un bloqueo de 55
horas desde este viernes por la noche
hasta el lunes por la mañana también se
impuso un toque de queda nocturno entre
semana y las escuelas están cerradas
generando incertidumbres en los
residentes
estoy preocupado por micrón hoy fui a mi
oficina pero ahora nos dicen que el
personal no puede trabajar al 100% de su
capacidad así que trabajaré solo 1510
este mes es posible que mi salario se
reduzca todo eso aumenta mi ansiedad el
'toque de queda' del fin de semana ya
está aquí podría convertirse en un
cierre total lo cual es muy preocupante
para mí ser actor en casi dos años de
pandemia 483 mil 178 personas han muerto
en india a causa del y coronavirus la
campaña de vacunación del país se ha
inmunizado en casi un año además de
623.000 como 2 millones de personas con
las dos dosis de la vacuna y al menos a
75,1 millones con una